welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is reid and we're here to talk
about literally anything guys i'll talk
about mr beast i'll talk about talent
management you guys lead the
conversation cool well thank you so much
for uh first of all coming out to las
vegas you're happy to be here we did a
poker tournament we did that was a lot
of fun and jimmy got out two hands in
which i'm sure we'll get into but a lot
of fun it was a blast but i'm excited
you could come on here we could talk
about how you got started because you're
the ceo of knight media you manage a
whole bunch of people including mr beast
so
yeah uh
you know just a little like i'll give
you guys yeah the context of you know i
was an nfl sports agent so worked with a
lot of different nfl players like right
out of college ended up meeting a
youtube group named dude perfect who i'm
sure a lot of people are familiar with
at this point
and then started my business in 2015
really representing video game youtubers
and twitch streamers and that was kind
of the start with typicalgamer who was
still the biggest live streamer today
and then i met jimmy through a twitter
dm in 2018 a friend of ours just started
a twitter group and he was like you guys
need to meet jimmy had like 1.3 million
subscribers at the time which is crazy
to say now
um and we just kind of hit it off from
the beginning and it's now been you know
almost three years that we've worked
that we've been like working together
now when mr beast was at 1.3 million
what were the amount of views he was
getting back then like was he was he a
big 1.3 million was he getting like you
know 20 000 views a day what was his
status like back then he was actually so
this was like right when he did his um
like giving pizzas away and giving five
thousand dollars to a homeless person
yeah and he had just got done watching
uh it's every day bro for 24 hours
straight so he was actually pulling like
uh one to two million views of video wow
um so he was he was significantly
pulling more views per video than
subscribers at that time but he still
hadn't hit that like crazy growth yeah
so when you stepped in
how did the relationship form is you
managing him yeah so it was a small team
uh when i first started it was him and
chris and then he had an editor and then
his mother kind of helped with all the
management financials everything like
that and so it was just like me building
a rapport with her and jimmy over the
course of like four months uh and then i
just started taking over basically all
the brand stuff that he was trying to do
and then now pushing into like different
companies and things that we wanted to
do together but it was a slow burn um
i'm more about like liking the people i
work with having a relationship with
them and so it wasn't something where i
was like hey man i want to manage you i
know i just met you last week we
actually took a lot of time to get to
know each other spoke a lot on the phone
i could tell like the moment i met him
he had a different understanding of
youtube that i had not heard before and
so it was a really interesting like few
months just like getting to know this
kid who at the time only had a million
subscribers but he kept telling me he's
like i will have 10 million subscribers
by the end of the year and this was
february of 2018
and we ended up i think he ended up with
13.6 million by the end of that year wow
and what exactly does like managing me
like mean to a creator and what kind of
creator would need a manager yeah i like
to say it's more like babysitting than
anything
especially with some of the bigger
creators now because they have just so
much so many things around there like
i'd say like ecosystem right they have
all these people asking for things they
have all these brands wanting to spend
money they probably have like a
charitable initiative
and and my philosophy has always been
you know if you can grow enough
like distribution if you can grow a big
enough brand then we can build
businesses around that right and so with
jimmy like we do things like mr
beesberger we did things like finger on
the app and we're gonna continue to
launch companies and so i think my role
as a manager has changed from hey i'm
gonna help you with like brand deals to
now i'm really just your business
partner helping you execute on all these
other things outside of just content
yeah how did you get into the management
of creators on youtube uh a cold email
to dude perfect in 2014.
that's how i got into it so i didn't
have any help or handholding i had to
learn this all by myself there wasn't a
book that i could read of like how to
get into this and at the time in 2014
people weren't really managing youtubers
it was more like mcn's at that time and
they were just rolling up creators and
so
i tell people this all the time if you
want to get into talent management just
start small go find a creator whose
content that you really like that has a
hundred thousand subscribers that you're
willing to bet on and just it hopefully
you get along with them and hopefully
you guys hit it off and you should just
start working for that person and being
their manager that's how that's how i
would tell someone to get in the
business but you were in sports before
so why did you leave sports to go for
youtube my cousins they were watching so
i was working with amazing like i was
working with like barry sanders and
marcus allen like amazing hall of famers
heisman trophy winners and when i met
dude perfect at the time i was loving
working as an nfl sports agent
but i just thought that you know i i was
i was a little concerned that they
weren't taking advantage of twitter and
youtube and these different social
mediums that were popping up and so when
i met dude perfect it was just like a
breath of fresh air of someone that was
actually like living on the internet
creating content every day being in like
the attention and so when i spoke to my
little cousins about it the first
question was like hey guys do you know
who dude perfect to us and they flipped
out and do perfect at this time only had
like two million subscribers they were
small
um and i just kind of knew like okay if
my
nine-year-old cousins are freaking out
about this creator they have no idea of
like any of the football players that i
worked at that time didn't know any of
them didn't care and it just kind of hit
me they're like okay this is where i
think the attention is going this isn't
going to stop youtube's going to
continue more channels are going to
continue to pop up and it was just
something i dove into left my job as a
sports agent which i tried very hard to
get into and that's when i lived in las
vegas
and i think everyone in my life kind of
thought i was crazy because youtube in
2014 wasn't really a job like right
people didn't think it was a business
yet and so it's like
just kind of had to prove myself over
those like two years how did you how do
you prove yourself with dude perfect
though uh it was just providing value it
was uh so the interesting conversation i
had with them really early on was i
thought they were doing a really good
job with basketball football like
traditional sports but they were missing
golf soccer some of these other things
that i thought they should be doing
trick shots in and so i went to callaway
golf and i spoke to the cmo and i
convinced them to spend a lot of money
on like multiple dude perfect videos and
then they started making golf trick shot
videos and the first one was with jamie
sadlowski won the long drive
championship and that was kind of their
inroads to golf and that's really how i
built trust with them was just providing
value before anything else so when you
do something like that do they sponsor
the videos or how does that work so like
the ball
the ball that they play within is like
product placement everything ball clubs
bag
we played it like a callaway performance
center like they literally outfitted the
whole video but there was no they never
stopped the video to do like an ad read
which you see youtubers do now right you
stop for six seconds like this is
brought to you by callaway golf that's
not how dude perfect did it and so it's
just organic branding throughout the
whole video and at the end of the video
they were like hey guys thanks for
watching if you want to buy these new
like callaway xr irons go to the link
we're going to have exclusive videos on
callawaygolf.com and that was kind of
the call to action and that's how dude
perfect solo video such a good pitch
super smash gosh because if i'm into
golf and i saw that
watch the entire video at the very end
i'd want to do that
that's really good get now can we ask
like what they pay for something like
that oh six figures yeah at the time
yeah and then duper who's averaging you
know five six million maybe a little
more views per video so it was a six
figure per video deal
for again like you're like hey i stopped
my videos and do a 45 second ad read and
it sometimes hurts your average view
duration yeah for them it was like we're
not going to kill our abd like we're
just going to show them throughout the
whole video and it works better wow
so from there
uh what what do you take from something
like that like a percentage right i i
take it is it a percentage yeah so okay
how how talent energies usually work is
they take a percentage of income it's
similar to an agent right where revenue
brought in or found money is then
commissioned right and so that's how i
made all my money with dude perfect
which is commissionable income wow
that's super interesting i see a lot of
parallels actually between what you did
at the time and what i did when i first
started working with graham like i just
shot him a cold email and basically
provided as much value as i could
basically free because i would
effectively take a commissioned amount
you know based off the money that i
brought in for graham yeah we developed
a relationship from there and then i
just tried to provide value and grow the
brand in any way that i could yeah
that's really interesting yeah and it's
different like it's it's for the to sign
like an nfl football player you have to
like travel to the college and watch the
games and talk to the parents it's like
a recruiting process
that's why i think that there's a lot of
youtube creators out there that need
help they really do they need help and
so back to like if you want to be a
talent manager just provide value to a
creator that you enjoy and you'll
eventually have yourself probably in a
unique position to help that person like
you did um in their the rest of their
career that's nuts yeah who is after
dude perfect uh typicalgamer
he was on twitch which was justin tv and
he was making the transition to youtube
gaming which was completely new at the
time and i met him at an event with an
nfl football player that we represented
and we just kind of hit it off and
continued to talk for like a year and a
half that was different though so andre
his name's andre he didn't answer my
phone calls or texts for like weeks on
end but i just stayed persistent
i just like every other week i would
text him and be like hey what do you
think about this what do you think about
this and that took like two years to
grow that relationship
and now we're extremely close to this
day but i just wouldn't lay off i was
like i truly believe that this guy is
going to be in a unique position in five
years and i really got along with them
because the only issue is just didn't
answer my phone calls yeah
so when you call them though what was
the pitch or what what did you want to
bring to him that he was ignoring there
was really no pitch like i don't pitch
creators i i think that's like something
an agent does they like bring you in a
room they give you the whole like dog
and pony show of like here's what we're
gonna do for you to me it's more about
like hey i really enjoy your content
let's get to know each other if we get
along let's see if we can do business
together there's like no pitch right
like hopefully my track record speaks
for itself with all the creators i've
worked with now
and it's to me like we don't represent a
lot of creators i think we represent 22
creators right now it's just it's more
about like having a deep relationship
with those creators and then we also we
try and represent the number one or
number two channel in each content
vertical uh and so that's that's kind of
our interesting
you know thing with night media is like
we're not going wide we're not just like
signing a thousand creators that's not
our business model um but with andre it
was just a slow burn um i just liked him
as a person and i was like i wanna
be close to this person if i'm gonna
have a business in this industry yeah
what was the first thing you did for mr
beast
um
other than all those phone like late
night phone calls at 1am about him
talking to me about like the youtube
algorithm the first thing i did for him
was uh the honey ad
we uh i got introduced to this guy who
used to be at meundies and he had just
left to go to this company
i remember this is years ago they
partnered with casper and casper was a
was one of my first clients in real
estate believe it or not uh it was 2009
this guy samir
uh was working in a different startup
representing him on a deal and then he
was one of the first people at casper in
the ipo i haven't talked to him in years
but uh yeah and then they did a
partnership with me undies there we go
great works with me on these um
indirectly yes okay but not directly
with them all right we need to get you
back in the undies
first we have to thank our sponsor of
this podcast attitude it goes without
question that sleep is crucial to how
productive you are the next day and that
is exactly why i love to have a good
mattress soft pillows graham tucky man
at night wait what and also high quality
bed sheets on a serious note guys i
actually consider good sleep material as
an investment because if i have a good
night of sleep i know that next day i
will be so much more productive and
successful and that's exactly why we
love having attitude bed sheets in our
bed seriously guys they are the comfiest
and softest bed sheets i ever had and
they are made of a hundred percent
bamboo which unlike cotton that uses a
bunch of water bamboo is actually the
most resource efficient plant on this
planet and because it's made in the most
sustainable way you know that you're
getting bed sheets that are free of
harmful chemicals and also the best for
you and the planet and honestly guys
graham keeps the thermostat way too high
to save money but these sheets are so
breathable that they actually can help
me sleep all the way throughout the
night without having to wake up due to
uncomfortable heat so if you want to
change the way that you sleep try
attitude for 30 nights and if you don't
like it return it for a full refund and
you can also get twenty percent off your
order today plus free shipping when you
go to etitude.com iced coffee and don't
forget to enter promo code iced coffee
during checkout remember that is
attitude as an eco attitude order today
for 20 off plus free shipping at
etitude.com
iced coffee thank you so much attitude
for sponsoring this episode and back to
the podcast to the podcast
but anyway so brian left to go uh to
honey
met him through twitter dms again like
twitter is like the plug to meet people
uh still us today and uh just had a
conversation with him about jimmy he
thought the channel was interesting and
we inked our first honey deal
honestly don't remember what the video
was but i remember the second video we
did with honey was donating 40 000 to
ninja ninja was doing a charity stream
and this was like 20 2018 ninja when he
was like bigger than life right fortnite
was huge and we did a forty thousand
dollar donation to him on twitch and it
was like over the course of an hour we
were like donating a thousand dollars
and five thousand dollars and he was
playing fortnite and the charity stream
was if you donated like five hundred
dollars he had to drop his guns if you
don't like a thousand dollars he had to
drop all his mats and so it was more of
a it was like a donation game and jimmy
ended up donating 40 000 all of which
was what honey basically paid us to do
that ad and he just gave it all away uh
that was like the first one that i
remember
who came up with that idea that that's
got to be jimmy right jimmy 100 yeah
yeah and it started with the homeless
person like he did a video with a quid
do you remember that like um they had
like stickers like mobile stickers oh
yeah this was like like three years ago
and anyway he did a deal with quidd and
uh i can't remember what they paid him
but he gave it all away uh to a homeless
person and that video did well and that
kind of started that trend of just like
giving away the brand money got it what
about the logistics behind the scene how
do you play into that because i know
with a lot of his videos it's so
intricate there's so many moving parts
do you have a hand in that oh i'm glad i
don't yeah the only time i ever handed
it is if they need something difficult
done um like for well i don't know if i
can say this but we booked a massive
venue last week and they're like hey we
need this venue for a specific video and
i was like all right i got it so if i
need to do something big or get a space
or a celebrity or something in his
videos i'll step in but he has a large
production team now that handles
logistics pre-production post-production
uh it's a little bit different machine
than it was when i first met him yeah
what was the weirdest request
exactly in my life or just like from
jimmy let's do both um let's start with
jimmy and then in your life oh man i
think the weirdest request i mean
there's probably a few i can't talk
about just because we uh we'll have like
future videos and stuff coming out okay
but i think some of the weirdest
requests have just been some of the
celebrities we've tried to get in videos
yeah and then what's funny about it is
you all usually talk to their agent or
their publicist and their kids are huge
fans
that's like our inn and so this one uh i
won't say his name but big name actor uh
contacted us and he was like hey my kids
really want to facetime with jimmy we're
like all right great like here's his
number do it and we're gonna need a
favor from this person because we want
him in a video down the road yeah but
i've had some interesting celebrity
requests from jimmy that i would have
never thought that he wanted to have in
videos wow
that's so cool yeah and we have i mean
we film at a lot of locations i think
like the conversation that i had to have
with him about remember when he gave
away an island yes it's called jeff uh
anyway like try taking that phone call
hey uh we're gonna film a video in two
months i need we need to buy an island
like i was like how do you buy an island
like who sells islands right and so that
was an interesting phone call of like we
need to find an island so i can give it
away and you basically just needed to do
the entire part of finding the island
finding someone who's willing to sell
their island yeah and organize that yeah
i mean thankfully his cousin knew
someone that knew someone that owned an
island um which ended up becoming jeff
and then given away in that video but i
had absolutely no idea and so it's just
like a few days of brainstorming about
like how on earth are we gonna do this
and actually how expensive is an island
like is this millions of dollars like we
had no idea
here's something before we go into the
weirdest request of your life
but how do taxes work because i'm so
curious if someone gets let's say ten
thousand dollars worth of a mystery box
are they claiming that or is is jimmy
yeah uh paying the tax that's a good
question so early on uh we would pay
most of the taxes so if we would give
away a car or something we would always
pay the taxes now it really depends on
what we're giving away but we're pretty
good about having them film out fill out
forms yeah especially on paypal so if
we're giving away x amount of money on
paypal we'll have them fill out a 1099
so they handle taxes on their end but
it's something that we actually used to
take care of and then we just like had a
conversation about it like hey we
probably shouldn't be paying taxes on
everything we're giving away because if
you're giving away a million dollars for
the stuff in that tax bracket i mean
jeez you could be paying 30 of that just
in tax on top of what you're giving away
yeah well did okay so the million dollar
video do you guys remember when um they
did the last to
take hand off like this giant thing of
money and had a million dollars yeah uh
and in the video jimmy actually did like
two minutes of meeting an accountant
talking about paying your taxes talking
about being like financially responsible
then meeting a financial advisor to set
aside a certain amount of money for him
and so we actually talked about that in
that video because yeah you give away a
million dollars 40-ish percent of that
is gonna just go right to uncle sam
right i did a reaction this is actually
i think how i got introduced to jimmy
this was two years ago he did a video uh
spending a million dollars in 24 hours
that was the video right after this yeah
and so many people reach out to me dude
you gotta comment on this you he's
blowing out of his money he's gonna go
bankrupt and i was like you know what
i'm gonna actually watch this video and
put a thoughtful response together and i
made this video put a thoughtful
response together
and uh i think jimmy sent me an
instagram dm or you know what you know
what it was i was blown away i was just
checking instagram and randomly i said
mr beast is following you like just as
i notifications like wait what is this i
thought it was fake so i clicked on it i
was like it's actually him like wine i
think at the time he's only following
like 190 people and so i sent him a
message and i guess he watched the video
he liked it yeah um and i talked about
it yeah
but uh i was blown away and that video
did really well but uh i was so careful
because i didn't want because i knew
like he had done this incredible gesture
it's like giving away i've never given
away a million so who am i to sit behind
a computer like criticize this so i was
so careful and like coming off the right
way and like making sure it was
respectful but like provided some humor
into the situation but what was your
thought on that uh i remember watching
the video and then jimmy and i kind of
had a discussion around it the thing was
we were a little worried when everyone
started talking about the paying taxes
and having an accountant because then
that started the conversation on the
internet of like how much is jimmy
paying taxes is jimmy paying taxes and
then i get a call from his accountant
and he's like there's people calling me
there's people sending me emails like
asking about jimmy i had no idea how
people got his email address
and so it kind of just like spiraled and
people started talking about it remember
there's like articles that came out and
like business insider about jimmy paying
taxes and things like that so that was
our i think i remember that was our
initial reaction is we're like is this
gonna draw light to this and then are
people gonna just like start asking
questions about like jimmy's giving away
all this stuff is he paying taxes and so
that's actually like what was the
biggest worry of that but it was a
really well done video thanks yeah um
but yeah that was that was the
conversation him and i had i'm curious
what with the worry about with taxes
what's the concern on that i mean not
really anything because we pay our taxes
right
but we just didn't want people digging
into it and like talking about it like
we wanted people talking about the
spectacle of the videos we didn't want
people talking about like does jimmy pay
taxes on a million dollars right or how
how does jimmy give away all this money
like we just wanted people being like
wow i can't believe he's like giving
money to homeless people and doing all
this good and these videos are crazy and
so we just don't want people having that
conversation
that's interesting
because uh
usually the i i feel like um at a
certain point people are going to look
for anything and i'm sure especially
with him
every single piece of information he
puts out there there's someone looking
for like what angle could i spin this i
told you yeah we just had that i showed
you guys that picture of john cena yeah
so jimmy had his stockx so you got these
yeezys from stockx and you remember
there's like a little emblem on them
when you get them it's like green and he
left the uh that little thing on the
shoes and the sneaker reddit is on fire
this morning about jimmy leaving so it's
like every little thing
i think they just think it's funny that
he didn't take the tag off and so
they're just like meaning him for it on
reddit so it's just like every little
thing is under a microscope got it so
you have to be super super careful
whenever he's in like you know the
public eye or anything you said he went
on a podcast yesterday yeah and that you
had to kind of like hyper monitor him
while he was speaking on the podcast
because you know he's under like a
microscope yeah i can't do much because
they're they're filming it like i can i
can stand up and be like we can't talk
about that yeah um but yeah he said
something about a company that you know
we didn't want out yet and i mean it's
out there now um when that podcast comes
out so i try um we've had situations in
the past where we've had to cut little
snippets out of like a podcast that he's
filmed because we're like hey we're
announcing that in two weeks and this
podcast is going to come out before that
right but for the most part he's really
good he's gotten a lot better um it's
just like interviewing talking to people
not spilling information from the things
that we've been working like he just
gets excited about stuff yeah and i just
want to talk about it yeah he's like i
just want this out here i know we're
announcing i'm just you know i'm just
going to talk about yeah and then i
stand up and i'm like
no
change the subject is there anything
you've had to say no to um
tons uh yeah so a good example so it was
about three years or two and a half
years ago and i started working with
jimmy what was becoming really popular
were these like mystery loot crate like
internet sites where you it's basically
like cs go skins but you'd go on and be
like here's the supreme box and you'd
pay fifty dollars for it and remember
yeah they didn't write ricegum did uh
yeah quite a few people yes yeah yeah
yeah they got a lot of hate for that
right jimmy was um he wanted to work
with that company when he heard about it
because it was a lot of money and we
wanted to give that money away in a
video and i had to talk him back on it i
was like listen we're not promoting
gambling i think people are going to see
this negatively so there's a long
conversation that him and i had to have
which eventually we passed on the deal
and then jake paul and ricegum ended up
doing that deal and got a lot of hate
for it yeah um so we've we've
sidestepped a few situations by just
having longer conversations him and i
have a really good relationship so when
stuff like that comes up like him and i
just get on the phone i hear him out he
hears me out and we just kind of discuss
like what we think we should do and we
ended up passing and it was a great pass
that was a smart move to pass have there
been other things like that where you've
looked back and you're like i'm so
thankful i didn't do that
all the time really all the time um not
just like on brands but just on like
pr and appearances and yeah all the time
how does he remain out of the spotlight
for like negative controversy because
i've noticed very little with him or
pretty much nothing or anything that
does come up i'm like i'm usually siding
with him like that's kind of silly to
you know take it out of context yeah uh
i mean he just like he's in north
carolina like he films youtube videos
he's not in the la drama scene uh he
doesn't engage with drama on the
internet and also like he he doesn't
drink like we we don't do any of that
yeah we don't really go to parties we're
not part of that crew
and so that's that's how he stayed out
and he didn't do anything in the past
that was wrong which you know usually
people are penalized for being a 14 year
old that said something stupid because
when jimmy became famous or started to
become famous he was 20 years old
and so like yeah i mean people say stuff
that when they're 14 or 15 that they
regret but they also don't know they're
going to be this internet icon when
they're 20 years old um but yeah he just
doesn't have a troubled past he doesn't
really have skeletons in the closet at
all so
it's not really sidestepping we just
don't have it we don't don't have
anything to hide i'm interested in
exactly like what you do with jimmy so
you basically just see him as a company
and then
act as like like branches to just to
just reach out to any other business
opportunity possible yeah so i mean it's
again changed a lot uh it used to be
like i was facilitating his brand deals
which you know there's a lot and now
there's five channels so brands across
all five channels we have a charity
channel that now is working with brands
thankfully like i have other people
within night media that handle that so
i'm not as involved because we have a
massive burger company that i have to be
really involved in on a day to day or
weekly basis on the marketing end and
what are we doing for like lto items we
have another company in the software
space you guys saw like the like finger
on the app yeah the second version of
that uh and then we're working on
another company that will be announced
probably in the next like 90 to 100-ish
days that him and i actually have been
working on for two years wow it was an
idea that we had like in a parking lot
uh and came up with a name and
everything like two years ago and so
we've been working on this company that
will eventually come out so a lot of my
time
goes into like his other businesses
talking to his like publicist i just i'm
here with him right so we played in that
he played in that celebrity poker
channel with you um so it's just it's
it's transitioned a lot from hey do this
brand deal to hey i need help on
everything business right everything on
the business but how do you get
compensated if i can ask like on those
different things such as like finding
the island or you don't i mean that's
just nature of being a manager right you
don't really make money on a lot of
things you do but you do it to provide
value to that creator right i would
never say no if one of our clients
called up and they're like hey i really
need help on this can you guys help me i
know you're not gonna make money on it
we would never be like nah sorry um and
we also don't we don't work with that
many people for that reason like we like
to be in the weeds in their businesses
we like to understand their pain points
and we like to identify people for them
to hire that we think will help them
grow and so it's just you do those
things as a manager without any just
monetary upside but that's just part of
the business right that makes sense yeah
uh so in terms of all of these
businesses where do you see the future
going for a lot of this uh because it
seems like you could set up some of
these apps as something to sell off yeah
because a finger on the app how do you
have any idea how much that's that's
worth finger on the app yeah like if we
were to put a valuation on that because
i would imagine gosh
how many millions of people signed up
for the app yeah i mean we had over 2
million downloads 1.5 million concurrent
players on the second one i mean a huge
huge
um game but so but i think the only
issue with finger on the app is it's not
repeatable right now we just did it as
like a a spectacle on a weekend for
people to play i think if we could
figure out how to turn that into like a
repeatable gaming like business then
maybe it would be worth a lot of money
um we're just like pretty focused on a
few other projects right now so mr
beastberger is i think a good example of
something that him and i put a lot of
work into i think there's a massive
valuation on that company
as well as this other company that we're
going to launch that we raise capital
for
and so yeah eventually like we either
sell those companies we go public i
think there'll be a liquidity like
three four years down the road i'm not
sure what that's going to be yet but
that's the goal right that's why i work
with jimmy and some of these creators
because i think they have a really
unique opportunity to build these
businesses it's all about attention
right the world is about attention right
now and i think jimmy is one of those
people that just always has the
attention on him because of his videos
and now if we can figure out how to like
solve different pain points or you know
build like a restaurant business that
people actually want to consume because
they believe in the person running it
those are the things that that i think
are like the long-term wins got it who
came up with mr beast burger and why why
mr beast burger yeah so uh we got
pitched by this uh this company who's
our partner in mr beast burger and it
was just a single restaurant in la that
they were opening and we ended up
passing on it but they like lightly
touched on hey we're also working on
this virtual dining business where like
you launched and it was like at the time
they were just like you launched you
know 100 virtual locations i was like
wait wait hold on tell me more about
that because that sounds interesting and
so we started having this conversation
with them about what that would look
like how big could this get and with
everything jimmy it's all about like is
it a spectacle like is it big enough for
people to be like holy cow that's
amazing like of course mr beast did that
and so our first question was like if
we're going to do this mr beesberger
thing can we launch it day one where
it's a big enough spectacle where the
internet's gonna be like i can't believe
he pulled this off and so after a lot of
conversations uh between myself and that
company and our president a few other
people in knight media we decided that
hey we think we should take this to
jimmy they're confident they can launch
with 300 plus locations day one and we
could have a pretty sizable restaurant
business uh in the next 90 days which
was crazy to think about and so when we
pitched it to jimmy he was like it was a
no-brainer
it was like big enough spectacle also he
had a video idea so it's opening the
world's first free restaurant which is
like the next big thing it's like yeah
great idea how do i make a good youtube
video out of that because that's all
he's concerned about and so once we had
those two pieces figured out it was just
sprinting to get as many locations as
possible
wow yeah i was actually blown away
because initially i thought it was just
a bit uh like uh not gimmicky but that
it was like a short-term thing like it
would just be you kind of talk about it
you get you get it once and never again
how many people now reorder yeah about
40
wow
yeah it's um
i mean the business is doing great we
have over 800 locations i think we're
closing in on a thousand actually we
open the uk we have we have you know a
lot of like locations in canada and
we're working on different countries
right now and so it was never supposed
to be like just a gimmick yeah i think
for us we're like we know this can be a
big business it's all about you know in
the virtual space like getting to scale
as quick as possible because i think a
lot of creators in the next year are
going to launch like
i don't know five in la right and it's
it's fine that's a great it's cool um
but think about launching a thousand mr
beesberger locations and then you can
launch lto items we did the miss the
dream burger and so now we can do all
these different collabs we can do new
menu items we can also fulfill
other items through those locations so
instead of just selling hamburgers we
could do merchandise and people can get
merchandise in 30 minutes or 40 minutes
and so there's just so many
possibilities i like to talk about this
yeah it's like you almost have like
almost like distribution centers across
the world where you can instead of
someone getting a t-shirt three to four
days you know from shopify we can be
like hey we're actually gonna fulfill
this through mr beastberger and with
your hamburger you can also get a a hat
or a t-shirt
that's cool are these businesses that
you're building up all like something
that you're planning on selling off at
some point in the future or do you plan
on just continuing to that hasn't been
the goal like we never started any of
these businesses to be like hey we're
gonna build this and sell it i think for
us like especially with jimmy we're just
like well let's build sustainable
businesses that people care about that
we think can last beyond jimmy's just
youtube career and so i think eventually
like we might be in a position to be
like hey should we sell this should we
take this public but it wasn't something
that we had thought about like when we
started the business which i think too
many people do to be honest i think a
lot of and it's like we have a venture
firm and we invest in a lot of software
companies and i think one thing that i
don't like is when founders talk about
just like selling the business hey i'm
starting this to sell the business or
something like that i never started
night media to sell night media i
started because i loved youtube i love
the space i love content creators and i
think a lot of successful businesses
that have been built are started by
founders who are just hyper obsessed
about building that product and now it's
a lot of like hey we see that we see a
need we're gonna build this we're gonna
sprint for two years and then hopefully
sell it and that happens a lot but for
us that wasn't that's not the goal yeah
where do you see the future going for
youtube
the future i would bet on youtube over
probably get a lot of criticism for this
i'll bet on youtube over any social
platform that currently exists over the
next five years without question
instagram twitter not even close
they're not even in the same atmosphere
i don't even think tick tock's in the
same atmosphere as youtube right now
monetarily and there's no other social
platform on the internet where you can
build a business right now as a content
creator like an actual business i think
you can have an instagram with five
million followers and you can do a
couple sponsored posts a month but you
can't really build a massive business
around that just think of how many
youtubers now have 10 million
subscribers that have massive production
companies that have multiple channels
that just doesn't exist on any other
platform to this day and i just still
think youtube is just strategically in a
different spot than anyone else i see
youtube though integrating a lot of tick
tocks features in terms of uh both
youtube shorts
and they're really pushing that home
page where i scroll down like three
videos and there's like a few things
where once you click on it it basically
takes me to
what i feel like is just
tick tock except on youtube
what are your thoughts on on youtube
shifting in that direction i mean i
think like it'd be hard for them not to
build that product
what's been really interesting is
someone launches a a product or feature
and then every other social company
copies them yeah we saw that with
stories right and then it was like reels
and i can't remember what the one on
twitter was
so everyone copies them i think the same
thing's happening right now is tick tock
has grown significantly quick because of
just short snippet videos youtube has no
choice but to implement that
it'll be the to me it'll be interesting
to see if youtube is just shorts in five
years and long form is just it's it's
hard so let me tell you let me tell you
jack i had this conversation last night
okay
here's my thinking youtube is pushing
the tick tock format a lot
youtube's smart you're not dumb
my thinking is this okay
uh
youtube you go on youtube you're
watching at least like five to ten
minutes of content let's just say i've
seen the effect of tick tock on people
including myself i hate tick-tock sam
but i go on there and all of a sudden
i'm on there for
six to 11 minutes just
endlessly scrolling my brain something
happens and it's just
short circuits and i'm just sitting
there just like withdrawal coming out of
my mouth just like that
and uh and it's a great i've seen what
what uh and not what it does to macy but
i've seen how much macy enjoys that i
would say i
and maybe i'm way off here i dare say
she'll now she now spends more time on
tick tock than youtube
just
all the you know what you know what you
know what it is it's uh it's it's filler
that's all it is is you with with
youtube i'm sitting down like i'm eating
something i'm like taking time out of my
day i'm going to put on youtube video
watch it it's got my full attention
tick tock is something i've seen for
macy is uh she could literally just be
like walking it to the kitchen
tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock
getting ready getting ready tick tock
tick tock and sure there's youtube that
mixes into that but i'm wondering if
youtube sees that people are are
spending more time on the app watching
30 second clips then they are a really
intense 15 minute video yeah that's my
question and i bet that's the direction
is the session time higher for shorts as
you know it is or long-form videos
that's that's an interesting thing that
i would like to see from youtube is a
session time on an individual basis
actually increasing because now like you
said you go to the the app and instead
of trending button it's now shorts yeah
but eventually are we gonna hit the
youtube app and it's just going to pull
up shorts automatically you're not even
going to get need to press another uh
thing to get into it yeah that is
interesting you know what one other
thing i want to mention i don't know if
it was with you or somebody else or
maybe it was with you read where we
talked about ridiculousness on mtv was
that i don't know who anyway
okay so anyway we were talking about the
success of ridiculousness and why mtv
paid so much money rob wanted to retire
from that show and he had no intention
of of renewing that contract but mtv
offered him so much money uh to continue
for five more years that he's like i
would be stupid to turn this down it's
worth it for me to take this money but
the reason why ridiculousness did so
well is because they needed good filler
content in the background where you
could keep it on you don't have to pay
attention to it you could walk out of
the room for 10 minutes and come right
back and you missed nothing you could
keep it on there's music in the
background you could be in a party but
have that on in the background
and you could pick up and leave anytime
and it's just like every 30 seconds of
something new that's the direction i
think we're going is that filler content
which is new new new new new um even
with youtube i i feel like it's honestly
moving in that direction where if it's
not like something new something new
something you change change change our
attention spans are are blown
you've got to think of it like like to
sit down and watch 10 minutes anyway
like
even going and watching a full-length 30
minute tv show like that doesn't happen
anymore without pulling out your phone
and like the boring spots you're just
like scrolling something else right it's
it's mind-blowing that's that's the
direction i think we're getting
interesting but what is more valuable
like if you have a lot more people
watching tick tock or whatever and more
time spent on that than on youtube like
could youtube still be more valuable
because of the relationship that the
consumers build with the creators
because you can build like you set
businesses and stuff off of youtube but
on something like tick tock it's it's
not very valuable to to be scrolling and
not to be developing relationships with
the creators and it's just like
something that your mind you're saying
is like a like a tick tock creator
versus a youtube creator well i'm sure
obviously youtube creator is more
valuable but for a business model right
like even if you do have more people
spending time on tiktok versus youtube
theoretically wouldn't youtube still be
more valuable because it's more you can
make more money off of it you can do
more like you said build businesses and
stuff yeah i mean that's my bet right
that's why i i think tick tock's great
and a lot of our clients use it i would
just rather they focus all of their time
on youtube right and that that's been
what i mean you guys have seen like what
our roster looks like it's all youtube
creators like we don't represent really
any native tik tok creators yeah you
can't really monetize tickets so here's
what i'm thinking okay here's here's my
thought for the creator youtube is a
hundred times better yeah but i think if
you look at what you get as a company i
think as a company you could be more
valuable with just that quick short for
content but as a creator it's way more
valuable to have the long-form content
so it just depends and here's what i
think too imagine instead of like the
top 10 creators making 80 of the money
instead it's reversed it's 80 of the
creators make 10 of the money and maybe
that business model is gonna be better
in the long term
so as a creator imagine i earn a
hundredth but i share that with a
bajillion other creators who are all
making a hundredth and we each
contribute our little 20 seconds into
you know every day 20 seconds 20 seconds
20 seconds but we share that split among
a bigger group a lot of the creators
that i know are transitioning from
tik-tok to youtube and a lot of the
youtube creators i know are struggling
transitioning from youtube
and the creators are i mean that's
they're doing so well but yeah i would
agree with jack it's so hard for me to
get into tick tock i i tried and uh god
i hate it i really do even even with
youtube shorts everyone has told me to
do youtube shorts but i'm like i just i
like the long form content everyone
knows it's good for you too like
everyone knows tic tocs are good for
creators but no one wants to transition
the reason why you need to do shorts is
because it's really good for
discoverability right it's like new
audience on youtube is tough like to get
i mean i know jimmy's gaining like 2
million subscribers a month but that's
like really tough to get to the discover
ability of youtube shorts is why you
need to be there right you need to look
at it as like top of funnel right if i
can if i in the the big conversation is
actually do you put it on your main
channel or do you create another channel
no i think that's the thing it would
need to be another channel
why do you say that do you think because
it would hurt you
i do i think it would destroy the
algorithm that uh i feel like i've spent
so much work crafting this algorithm
that works for the main channel and
people are accustomed now to
three videos a week monday wednesday
friday they know the time and throwing
in more i i personally like i look at
this where i get upset when i see shorts
i i don't know why when i'm in my
subscription feed and i see a short i'm
like that's taking a valuable space that
i'm not interested in yeah i don't mind
if it's within the short section of the
app because then i'm looking for it but
otherwise it's like you know you're
walking down the street and there's like
a big stone in the middle of the way i'm
like you know if i want to start i go
hiking
it's in my path so i don't like it so if
i don't like it i feel like other people
wouldn't appreciate it either i think
it's a new channel i don't care you're
exactly right and i've i've spoken to a
lot of creators about this and they'd
say the exact same thing but what i
think is coming is you're going to be
able to upload a youtube short to your
main channel and you're gonna be able to
categorize it whether it's a short or it
goes to your like long-form video feed
right and so when you upload a short to
your main channel it's not gonna show up
on your video feed it's just gonna get
sent directly into shorts and i think
that's when like you and some of these
bigger channels can take advantage of it
because i totally get it i don't want to
follow someone and then my sub feed
which i actually don't really click on i
just go to home page um but then it's
just littered with their shorts videos
because they're uploading every day i've
unsubscribed from those channels and it
takes a lot for me to unsubscribe
but when i see a channel that i'll watch
once a month but they're posting every
day is short and it's just it's more for
me to sift through every day and i'm
just i'm just trying to hone in on the
content i really want to see yeah but if
they found a way to do that yeah so a
good example is lankybox who's a client
of ours is they were and they were big
before the youtube shorts they were
doing like 500 million views a month on
youtube shorts they implemented or just
on without youtube shorts they
implemented youtube shorts in their main
channel and they're now doing 2.5
billion views a month so it's incredibly
valuable from like a new audience growth
perspective
and they've gained like 1.5 million
subscribers last month but it clogs up
their feed because they're posting three
shorts a day
i'm curious two things one what does the
revenue look like on that on a short
right now youtube has a shorts fund and
so you basically cash in a shorts fund
you go into your your dashboard and then
youtube's paying people out to create
shorts basically so there's no like cpm
model yet and i i don't know if we'll
we'll get there in the next year i think
youtube's got to figure out like okay
how are we are we how are we running ads
on youtube shorts for each individual
creator not like how snapchat does it
where they're like running ads in
between each clip yeah right because
then you really don't know how to like
which creator you're paying yeah the
other question i had what is the
conversion between the type of person
who wants to watch a short versus the
long form content because if it is a
funnel i would say just throwing out
numbers here maybe 85 90 of the people
who subscribe for shorts are not
necessarily interested in watching a 15
minute video they just want more shorts
so it seems like you're building out two
divisive audiences that each want
something different yeah that's the big
question and that's the question the
youtube channels that are just creating
shorts are gonna have to to answer and
figure out is if i'm building an
audience that's just here for youtube
shorts and so i've seen youtubers that
i'm sure you have now they're doing like
500 million views a month just doing
shorts right the big question is like
how do you create long-form content on
that channel and when you do upload a
video that's like eight minutes long is
anyone gonna watch it or are they just
there for shorts and it's a battle that
a lot of creators are fighting right now
because they're not making any money you
pull 500 million views a month you don't
really make any money so you want to
upload long-form videos so you can
actually run ads yeah and a lot of these
channels are really struggling they'll
pull they'll do like a million views per
short and then they'll upload an eight
minute video that'll get 20k views yeah
and so that's that's the question is
like how do you if you're if you're
bringing in this audience are they
converting to watch your long form
videos are they just there for your
shorts i have a couple of questions like
why first off why doesn't jimmy start a
podcast and second off do you believe
that a creator can over expose
themselves on social media and that they
could put out so much content that
people aren't as excited for when they
do post for example for me with david
dobrik he posts once a week or michael
reeves or idubbbz they post so rarely
so when they yeah but when they do post
it's like it's so exciting because you
haven't seen them in such a long time
and you are just that thrilled to watch
their content but someone else who like
for example we put out i don't even know
like nine videos
it's like do our the people that consume
our content are they less excited to
watch our content does it overall like
negatively affect our video or our
performance is there like a curve to
this i mean would you why if david
dobrik uploaded three vlogs a week would
you watch all three yes
that's hey you're right i mean if david
uploaded a vlog i mean if david dobrik
uploaded a vlog a day like i would watch
his four-minute vlog every single day
do you watch his content yeah of course
um i mean he's great right so it's
that's true uh and let's just look at
another example so like garyvee i think
is a good example of just content spam
it's everywhere and he's done a really
good job of building his brand like
everyone knows who gary is but i'm like
gary post a lot but here's the thing
gary is an example where i feel like he
did too much and he was again i i hit i
like gary's content but i he was one of
those first people i unsubscribed from
because he posted so much and sometimes
like two to three times a day
meet kevin is the only one
where uh he'll post like three times a
day and i watch all of them i watch like
90 of his videos but it's like a
business update so i'm interested but
you're also not gary's like fan base
right like
you're you don't need his motivation you
don't you don't need that stuff right
but i feel like his view to subscriber
ratio is not that good some of his
videos get like 19 000 20 000 views and
he's got like three million subscribers
do you think that it could be just
because this quality is suffering by
like you know what i'm just putting on
something i think it's too similar
that's that's the only thing you think
is very similar content every day
whereas david dobrik
if he was able to do three times a week
it would be so unique he did in the past
he did he used to upload three times a
week yeah and they were still very good
vlogs um but he again he's like it's
very difficult for me to get three good
vlogs a week i mean jimmy only uploads
two a month right we would love to
upload
didn't he used to upload once a week
we did i mean it's like it's been like a
giant roller coaster of trying to upload
once a week it's just the videos have
gotten so out of control that it's hard
to film like uh what was the latest
video we let's just take like
50 hours buried alive right it's hard
for jimmy to like prep for that video
get buried alive for 50 hours come out
of that coffin that's 10 feet
underground yeah and then film another
video two days later yeah so it's like
when when these videos start to get this
crazy it's really tough to consistently
film every week
uh do you ever feel like he's taken it
too much to an extreme in the sense that
like every video he has to find a way to
top it like i feel like he can't go down
from this it's like you're at the top
you have to keep building higher yep
is there ever a point where you feel
like how crazy like at what point do we
realize like
we we can't top this yeah i mean i've
seen the you know videos ideas that he
has down going forward you know this and
they're crazier than they are now so
at least in the next couple of years
like i don't see the videos going down
can you give us a few
ideas kill me yeah really no way
because they have to hit they have to
hit youtube and you guys have to be like
holy cow how did this video happen sure
right i think there's one of those
videos coming up next month you're gonna
be like again like i don't know how
jimmy did this and he talks about it on
logan paul's podcast actually because we
he filmed it a couple days ago yeah um
he's actually spending when's this come
out this will be a week from today about
a week
yeah i don't know if i can talk about
well you'll see it when it comes out i'm
not sure when logan's podcast is coming
out um but when you see the video title
you're gonna be like i don't understand
how he pulled this off like why would he
even put himself through this suffering
at this point in his life
um and again i've seen all i've seen a
lot of the video ideas like it gets
bigger everything's getting bigger you
know i've noticed he's expanded and
really brought on a team on his channel
was that strategic
because it's gone from really just him
to now he's got you know carl and he's
got everyone else in the group yeah he's
always you know when i met him it was
him in front of a computer donating to
twitch streamers but chris was always
there yeah and so we've just expanded
the talent a little bit and it's been
more of like making it a crew of people
that like some people show up to watch
carl some people show up for chandler
and it's like the dynamic between all
those guys and then also a lot of our
videos are challenges that involve a lot
of people like hide and seek for example
we need like eight people to play hide
and seek right and so you have to have
those crew of characters in your videos
and so it's taken a long time to find
people and to be honest a lot of them
had different jobs at his production
company like internally and then they've
been like hey this guy's actually really
funny like let's try them out in a video
and then they turn into carl jacobs
right so uh it's just like we're
continually looking for talented people
to be on the channel got it now but but
is that strategic in the sense that like
if jimmy wants to step back
he's still got a team of people who have
an audience who could continue
moving the whole brand forward yeah i
don't i don't think he'll ever not be
the main talent on the channel okay i
think that's a conversation that you
know a lot of youtubers are gonna have
to have like dude perfect like what
happens when dude perfect no longer
wants to be in the in the videos right i
don't know uh jimmy i think is like five
to seven years away from that decision
but he'll always be like the guy the
number one guy like the the reason
people come and then we have all these
other like funny characters in his like
ecosystem of that video got it i want to
ask you a question about our vlog we
have a vlog called the family down below
in the description
we have been i don't want to say
struggling
but uh struggling we've been struggling
yeah i would say it's uh we got off to i
think a a a false start that gave us a
lot more confidence the first vlog we
posted got like a hundred thousand views
just like right off the bat the second
vlog we posted a hundred thousand views
and we're trying to find out how to how
to do this in a way that's sustainable
and we've gone back and forth you know
right now we're posting an eight to ten
minute video once a week okay but i was
thinking once a week isn't enough so we
need to do twice a week so then my idea
was let's post shorter videos like four
to five minutes twice a week and just
spread it out you know mid-week but
then the average view duration goes down
significantly and we're noticing less
views on a shorter video than a longer
video
uh but then we're also struggling with
where do we find the time to do stuff
for the channel
jack and alex want to do content that i
think
is uh i'll say is immature like uh
putting a whole bunch of rubber duckies
putting a whole bunch of rubber duckies
in the pool i'm like they're trying to
pull views though right like people want
to see that my thought but that's not
sustainable my style is yes it is
it's only sustainable if you start
making enough money in your eyes right
it's like if the brand if this the
family can start making enough money
where it makes sense to do that kind of
stuff then it's sustainable to you but
just because it isn't making money right
now doesn't mean that it's not
sustainable and also let me ask you a
question how long did it take you to get
a million subscribers right let's say
like five years uh no no two two to two
years two and a half years okay well
anyway that's a long period of time
right yeah so it's like i think everyone
now thinks that they can just launch a
new youtube channel and it's gonna be
successful it takes time to like build
and because you're really building a new
audience for that channel because i
would imagine a lot of people that watch
your your channel your actual channel
don't go to that side channel to watch
you guys feel rubber ducks or watch you
fill a pool with rubber ducks right they
won't learn about stock market real
estate um at least me like i watch your
channel i don't know if i'd watch this
to family if it was like for you know 12
year olds if depending on what you see
but i don't know if that's the audience
i want like i thought a vlog about like
the behind the scenes of if both running
the channel the dynamic between all of
us here at the house
doing some fun stuff here and there and
that's like the first few vlogs were my
favorites because they were like jack
and i trying to do a thumbnail and it's
me on top of the roof of the ford gt try
not to break the car while there's a
drone hovering above and i'm trying to
like
like that for a thumbnail and like stuff
like that
but i don't know if i want to film
rubber yeah people are gonna get the
word if you if you film our everyday
life and stuff like that and the behind
the scenes of graham's main channel
content creation we are section like
we're
basically so much of that though on
youtube like behind the scenes like of
videos and stuff there's just there's so
many channels like that and we're only
pulling from our audience of your
channel and the reason i feel like the
best reason why we should have created a
vlog is so we can diversify our content
to go to a whole different audience
because right now we are in the personal
finance niche you know and i feel like
it is important to try to break free of
that so we can be a little more diverse
on youtube
why do you guys want to break free from
that yeah because you're it like you're
the biggest channel in that vertical
yeah my thinking is how long can i be in
front of the camera three times a week
making videos in finance as long as i
can is the answer but at a certain point
i know this is just going to be
something where it's like i want to try
something new and i think
uh if i could build up a vlog channel
big enough then i could start doing some
other stuff that i wanted to do like
traveling and then i could vlog the
entire thing turn it into uh you know
travel
uh van life stuff like that man
yeah van life i think it would be really
cool yeah that'd be good right so i'd
watch that yeah so why why isn't that
the channel the van life yeah we can't
do that yet not yet so my thought was
that like by the time i want to start
scaling back in the main channel instead
of maybe three a week i'm going down to
like one a week or something like that
going and traveling doing other stuff
but then the vlog channel is going to be
big enough where we could start
transitioning over to that did you ever
think that if you potentially build up
the vlog channel in that way by putting
rubber duckies in the pool and then you
all of a sudden switch it up and you're
like well guys we're transient people
and we're going to be traveling now
you think that that would have an impact
on views like because what if you build
it up to millions of so but that's why i
don't want to do rubber duckies because
i i want this to be a
mature audience who could appreciate
traveling so then start traveling now
and start your travel channel if that's
what you want i also i'm not ready to
step back on that i also think you could
upload less and you'd pull more views
per video or you'd pull the same amount
of views per month by uploading one
video less i don't disagree that's an
interesting one video less a month or a
week a week
i i don't disagree with that at all
i've had this conversation with so many
creators that were that used to do like
five videos a week and they've now
scaled back to two to three and they
actually pull more views per month than
they did when they were high five i've
noticed three seems like the sweet spot
and i'll tell you there's a few other
channels in the finance space that uh
have uploaded three and gotten out of
two and you see the views half what you
just need to make better videos they
make great videos but if you're but if
you're filming less videos per week then
those two videos you post per week have
to be exponentially better because
you're only posting two that's how you
have to think about i don't know if
those videos could be exponentially
better because i feel like the three i
do
uh maybe with the exception of maybe
like one every other week is like kind
of just i'm trying to rush it out but
most of them i put everything i have
into those videos so i'd like in my mind
i don't know how i could possibly make
those videos any better yeah i'll be
honest but if you had more time to think
about those two videos because you
didn't have to worry about a third do
you change no because sometimes i have
to get those videos out so fast like
i'll tell jack the day before i'm like
there's a topic that if this happens i
gotta get this video out so i'll plan
the whole video out ahead of time just
in case that thing happens i have a
whole outline that'll wake up early film
edit get it out the same day yeah
well i mean back to the vlog channel i
don't know if you want the same audience
on your regular channel as the vlog
channel i just think you guys need to
think a little bit more about like what
does a 35 year old want to watch on a
second channel
i i think with the vlog channel it would
make sense to post a little bit less
because a lot of the times we don't go
out of our way so much to create great
content and because of that you just see
a slow decline on views like although
subscriber growth is like it's
continuing to grow it i mean slower
granted uh the views are are continually
continuing to to decline because
the content we're just not putting as
much thought into it that's it's right
like so what's your recommendation
because my thought is we need a schedule
and i like having that schedule where
like every tuesday at 10 a.m we we post
vlog no matter what
we could just say when we get enough
content we'll post a vlog are we talking
about the new channel this is the family
family yeah family yeah
this is a fuffle
yeah first of all we need a new name we
need a name change you don't like the
staff
no dude honestly listen if you didn't
like it i would be happy yeah i would
seriously change it right now i would
seriously be open to changing it
definitely doesn't say hey graham
stefan's in this channel right like i
would never see that and be like oh
that's you know i thought gramp stefan
stefan
yeah that's like that
did you not get that that was a big mess
i think we got to rename the channel but
anyway okay you know what i'm i'm good
with that i'm good i'm saying i'm stefan
vlogs
i gotta i gotta think about it i can't
throw throw like something out here and
then you guys rename it i'm like i
absolutely hate that but
let's be clear you do not like the name
the stephanie i absolutely do not like
it
that works for us okay
that's enough for me if you guys would
have said hey there's this channel
called the sta family what do you think
that they make and i'd be like it's
probably some family like the ace family
that like makes like cringy like family
videos that was the initial idea was to
like kind of like
joke on that those types of channels and
that's why we called it this the family
but i guess no i never i didn't even
know that what
i thought this whole time dude that was
being serious in the first vlog we're
like welcome back to this family because
i thought cause i thought we were making
that i was making fun that's because i
always intro like welcome back to this
to family like that's all it is but
that's the joke but the name itself i
was serious with the name
all right we got we got some creative
differences we got to settle thank you
i'm glad okay you know i'm good we need
to settle this if we get anything today
let's change the image sure the vlog
yeah but the more important thing is the
content um what was the question you
wanted to know if like he uploaded less
you guys could do more to or you said
that you guys are pulling less views now
you're still uploading three videos a
week uh yeah i think i know why
the vlog channel is once a week yeah we
did twice a week but with shorter videos
and we noticed no difference in views uh
no difference in ad revenue uh watch
time went down significantly
so
when you guys make switches like this it
takes time right like you can't like
give it a week or two two weeks yeah
to be like hey did this work or not
that's true you have to commit to it you
have to be like we're gonna do this and
we're gonna commit to it for four months
and at the end of four months like let's
see what happens because what usually
happens is like a content creator will
make a pivot for a week and they'll be
like oh my views dropped and then
they'll go back to doing the same thing
where i've seen a lot of our clients
like do that and then i've convinced
them to be like just give it like two to
three months and they've seen the same
decline and then all of a sudden the re
it's shot up right and but they don't
give it enough time to see if that
change actually makes a difference
interesting okay
see my i guess the hard part for me is
that uh
like i i feel like i i can only allocate
so much time to everything and like the
main channel is my priority that that
comes over everything like that's the
bread and butter i'm not
sacrificing anything on that so the main
channel is it right after i'm done with
the main channel my second priority the
second channel so no matter what it's
then it's the second channel after that
then it's the podcast this get this out
of the way this is fine uh
i would say the lowest thing on the
totem pole is probably the the vlog
channel just because
there's so many other things i can't
dedicate to the time because otherwise
it literally will take away from
something else yeah
well you upload a video so you upload
three times a week at the same time same
day main channel will you upload a video
that like you're just like eh it's not
very good yeah but we still got to
upload yes but but i make everything
good enough for at least i would be
happy to post it yeah i i've never
posted a video where like i hate this
video it sucks i don't want to post it
i'm just going to post it anyway every
video is like it's not my favorite it's
a boring topic to me but sometimes those
are the ones that do the best
side hustles side hustles and passive
income those are the videos for me i
hate them i hate making these videos but
they do the best people love them it's
the best like ratio they get the most
views almost every passive income video
gets over a million views but i hate
making them but people love it yeah i
can see how that would be really popular
yeah on your channel oh yeah but it's
the same stuff so but but sometimes like
every video will reach a new audience so
my current audience will be like that's
a passive income whatever but every new
video is just like oh here's this
audience over here who needs a new video
posting last week on passive income this
is what we're going to recommend to that
group of people so they all reach a
completely new audience i think like
you're in such a unique position
because
the youtube audience that like me that
has been watching now for seven eight
years is is older yeah and now a lot of
my cousins that were nine years old that
started with dude perfect are now 17
yeah and they're like on their way
they're like they watch mr beast but
when they become 25 they're gonna find
your channel yeah and so as the youtube
audience gets older and older and older
your audience is just going to continue
to go up so i think it's just like
doubling down on making the best videos
possible for the main channel um and
the like
family channel
i'm not sure i need to watch the videos
um it seems like a cool like side
project i just think you guys need to
figure out what the hell the content is
yeah you know what i mean after after
talking i would be okay first of all
changing the name i'd be good with that
and then maybe we just vlog stuff and
when we post a vlog it's special
and that's what it is yes i agree with
that that's what alex and i have been
talking really okay yeah and that's what
we've been trying to mention i am such a
like i'm such a stickler for a schedule
i it because like the second channel
every all the channel we have such a
strict schedule we're like down to the
minute every video for years so to do
something where it's like you just
posting
on a whim
it's weird for me i i despise more than
anything posting bad content or content
i myself would not like to watch and
sometimes when we put out those to
family videos it's like i'm just
thinking to myself like see now you can
still
know you know this no it's not that no
it's the you said this to family and now
now i can't get this out of my scavenger
maybe you should rename it to scuff
family yeah
the scuffed family that's well you know
what honestly it takes a huge load off
my mind mentally but not worrying about
that vlog seriously i've because every
time we're like you also need to put in
more effort in it it's like the amount
of effort it's like maybe i'm not just
thrilled on it maybe i tried it it was
fun when i when it was just like behind
the scenes stuff where it was just like
i felt it was natural i enjoyed it but
when i'm putting effort into something
it's taken away from other stuff maybe
it's i guess we have a different idea
it's like i enjoy filming stuff for this
to family like if we go and we do
something silly or stupid or fun but
then we can film it organically yeah but
with this the family it gives us a
reason to go and do those things but if
we don't have that we won't go out of
our way to like do fun things
what do you think be a beer a beer
moderator no i think that i i love you
guys having more channels i think i just
need to understand like what the videos
are like when you say experiences like
are you guys going to certain places to
experience or like because i the rubber
ducky example is like we're just filling
the pool with rubber ducks and then i
it's like a prank video right right yeah
so like what's going on our way to do
like big bigger things uh that are fun
and exciting
for the reason of filming it you know
like i've also had a few ideas alex's
chair by the way is making the sound
no that's not my chair i guarantee you
it is
i thought i thought a duck was flying
overhead no i swear that's not the chair
see this is i swear it's not i would
hear it
it's not the change i wanted
another thing that i struggle and maybe
this is just me like
i feel like we also need like at least a
little bit of a budget graham doesn't
let me spend any money on the stuff i'm
a
yeah like i like like i tried to get him
to play poker the other night and he was
like i did
well because i knew i was throwing my
money away i knew that i gave it to
jimmy he took all my money did he really
yeah i did oh i went because he blocked
yeah his strategy by the way before we
go to this his strategy is bluffing 60
that was it you heard that right it did
not move but you heard that i heard it i
heard it yes
it sounded like you came from that side
are you stepping on ramsay like what is
this oh could it be the table move the
table
that's it
is the mic is the are the mics picking
yeah it's the table
but it was you
anyway all right
so you don't have a budget of the
channel yeah so the whole rubber ducky
idea came about because the whole video
concept was i filled my boss's pool with
rubber duckies and i didn't want to tell
him what it was i was like graham can
you trust me on this can you give me a
few hundred bucks to like
you know buy some no it was not a
thousand
and he you know he doesn't want to give
me any sort of budget not even you know
a few hundred bucks you know i'm not
going to like spend the whole do you
want me to give you the hundred bucks
how much money do you need probably
about seven hundred right i was like i
was like
i was like
no it was like i estimated it to be like
no more than 500 bucks is is the video
going to do well
we haven't tried now
outside of horn
no it was like surprising my boss like
something like that so ideally it would
be a surprise we have other surprises we
want to do but it does require funding
and
we just know for a fact
yeah we're going to need to put aside a
budget for this channel if we're doing
it yeah
but dude but do you like the idea
i mean it sounds fine
you're building a new from my
perspective you're building a new
audience because i don't think your fans
will watch this yeah
right so yeah it's like let's just take
the jimmy example right main channel
starts a gaming channel we're like
organic these fans are gonna watch them
play minecraft roblox fortnite whatever
does a react channel we're like we're
confident his fans are gonna watch the
reacts channel um so we're like
re-monetizing his the same fans over
multiple channels and yes there's new
fans for certain channels but for the
most part he was confident that hey all
my fans are gonna watch
my videos on these four to five channels
right where it's like my my like uh
concern is
your main channel is all about like
let's say say financial literacy and now
you're doing like this like prank pseudo
family the boys channel i don't think
there's a crossover i agree with that
but i don't think there is a way we can
orient this to family into being like
well you just gotta pivot the content it
needs to be a different channel that has
an overlap what would you recommend
because i agree with you the second
channel i was confident people would see
me react to finance content the podcast
100 was confident people want to see an
hour long video would watch it
everything just the family's the only
one where i felt they would a smaller
portion would want to see the behind the
scenes but yeah
i mean you just have to figure out
another content vertical that appeals to
an older audience right like i think in
my mind it's like cooking appeals to an
older fan base
travel
things like that so i think it's just
you have to think about what's and i
don't know what your average fan is i'm
guessing 30 right i would say probably
18 and the low end of 35 hundred okay
yeah so what do 18 to 35 year olds watch
i don't know not the ace family
you know what it probably honestly is
van life travel
really livi i love it i love that idea i
think it's living vicariously i think
you know what it is it's doing all the
things that you wish you could do and
you can all in those videos you can also
talk about the budget right of like how
much money do we spend on this like how
do we keep like these costs low so i
think there's a little bit of overlap
between the two channels on the budget
of like traveling and having unique
experiments or experiences on a low
budget you know what would be a good one
like uh staying in shelby church's new
um
uh airbnb
yes the springs you could do like the
five things you can do for less than a
thousand the five experiments
experiences you can have for less than
five thousand dollars stuff like that
yeah
i like i like that i like that
that's a good idea yeah right
because you can do an experience where
you're going to the world's largest uh i
don't know string of cheese that's like
200 bucks to get in right so you could
do like stupid experience like because
you so it could be a humorous channel
that's out of the box back into like
spending money i like that a lot yeah
200 bucks is out of the budget though
the ones that did take off in the
beginning were like
we're like more finance related like the
forty thousand dollar aquarium yeah like
that you know buying a new car like the
finance that was on the family yeah oh i
need to see the channel first so okay
but let me look at it but i think that
should be i honestly i like that and
then we could spend money on experiences
like uh like buying a 50 hamburger or
something like that like trying do you
like that idea or the world yeah the
world's cheapest hamburgers or the
world's yeah listen
you could probably put 100 ideas down
now that you kind of have a framework
for the channel but just again you want
it to appeal to the fan base that you
already have
right at least at the beginning because
you guys are like we want to pull views
we're only doing 50k views of video it's
because nobody that you know watches
your other videos cares yeah
i like that honestly this is so
insightful yeah and and for that would
you recommend sticking to a schedule
and doing that or would you recommend to
be honest or
uh
just when we have time we'll post a good
episode
i would rather you guys start like that
okay like when we post it's gonna be an
amazing video okay not like hey let's
force out two videos a week
right
jack okay let's just let just real quick
just
thank you thank you i gotta say this has
given me this last like 50 minute more
clarity on that channel because that
channel has
of my stress level i would say that
channel is up there with the main
channel believe it or not
because i have to think about like
fitting it in where can i fit it in
what what do you do
i don't spend any time anyway
because i think of it because it takes
up my mental capacity yeah also you guys
are in vegas like yeah we're in las
vegas right now you know how many videos
you can film like experiment like
experience videos for like certain
amounts of money or expensive i know
you're we're going to need to budget
like what
give us something helicopter
helicopters flying around vegas last
night that's a really unique experience
experience for under i don't know it's
not seven it's 500 if you want to i owe
them a helicopter 500 yeah so it's like
those things you guys need to take
advantage of and then you get to be the
boys can go on the helicopter you're
filming the video people know how much
money it is yeah you know that stuff
i like it
i gotta say i like it that uh
wow okay so
what what else is your advice for us or
for me or for the channel general advice
yeah just general life advice or like
general life what do you think
i'm 32
really yeah wow yeah you're you're older
than i thought you were there we go
that's yeah yeah you know what you could
pass anywhere from 26. but that's what
people always tell me yeah you look you
look younger but you act
older i'm a millennial yeah like i i'm
like at heart i'm a gen z i'm a zoomer
yeah yeah you could look like you could
honestly pass for like you just turned
21. yeah but i think it's like it's yeah
it's how i dress that's how i talk it's
like what i work in like i i totally get
it yeah
that's good yeah that's complicated
but general advice like i don't know i
think hopefully like my conversation
that we just had about this whole side
channel helps um i think if i if i was
you i would be doubling down on making
the best videos possible for the main
channel because you're i'm telling you
in the next three years you're gonna
find a lot of new fans okay people just
aging up to your content and you have to
be the guy
you have to be the financial literacy
guy whether it's crypto real estate
investing whatever you have to be the
guy in that space got it and so when
people age up and they're like hey i'm
25 i now like didn't learn anything in
college i don't know how to invest my
money i don't know what to do in real
estate they shouldn't even look they
shouldn't even think of any other
youtuber it should just be like graham
stefan and if i'm getting to the point
where i'm like
not burnt out but getting overwhelmed
with three a week or just like yeah then
then it's just go to two a week yeah
okay take it down j i mean yes would
jimmy pull more views per month if he
uploaded six videos as opposed to three
yes
but he's still averaging 60 million
views per video right so the bar is
still incredibly high so you're saying
that i would still ad most likely still
average the same amount of views but i
would just be
well and i also think per video yeah the
question is like um
at some point do the view does it matter
if you're pulling 25 million views a
month or 40 million views a month like
in the grant in the in the whole like
grand scheme of like money does it
actually matter like is is your personal
like happiness and mental health more
important than an extra x amount of
money yeah right because again i think i
don't even think the 10 to 15 million
views per month matters i think you're
so uniquely positioned to win in the
space on youtube that now it's just
continuing to like make good videos and
you not burning out
got it i guess for me my biggest i know
we're kind of going off a little bit my
biggest fear is that uh i i
need that sort of schedule and i know
as soon as i scale back i can't ramp
back up it seems like you have a lot
going on you have now you have you know
this family and you have all these like
channels and side projects you still
invest in real estate right you got to
like have a prioritization list
and then the big question is like when
you make that list it's like is are
these two things at the bottom important
enough for me to put any time into or
should we just kill them yeah right
because like your mental health is the
most important thing and especially that
the main channel is the the priority is
um then you know a lot of the work's
just going to continuing the main
channel at the highest level without you
taking a hit on your mental health
okay
yeah i think this is a family unless i
think we just post if we have a good
concept a good video we should we should
probably try to post twice a month on
that sure yeah i agree with it just a
good video for fun
but uh all right alex you're good with
that it frees up alex this time now uh
yeah but i have you doing some other
stuff it has to be like a great video
yeah i agree go to pawn stars and talk
to them about their business and like i
don't know i i would just have to think
a little bit but you guys are in vegas
yeah anything's possible all right
thank you so much for coming thank you
thank you it's great meeting you yeah i
feel like we had a good like business
meet like i feel like i i feel a little
hyped now it's like yeah me too yeah
that's why i'm a professional hype man
and yeah business management youtuber
space thank you so much oh and then i
also i got to give you some bankroll
coffee before you have room in your bag
i ordered some we did the podcast yeah
and i ordered a bunch and it came into
the dallas office but i'd already moved
to austin i was like hoping that i would
catch it on the day that it came in but
now my employees just absolutely
destroyed it
okay i'll give you more i'd love to take
some yeah so congrats on that as well
youtubers creating products like it's
just we're not even at first base yet so
i love it and we're uh we're doing one
with kevin he wants 1337 coffee so we're
releasing that in support of him running
as governor so it's like elite so uh
that should be for sale very actually by
the time this goes up it's going to be
for sale and then all the profit that we
make from that like basically all the
proceeds go to support his cause nice
okay yeah i'm into it so cool thanks
guys appreciate it thank you so much
thank you guys so much for watching uh
so read we'll put all of your
information down below in the
description where you could also get
your free stock that's now worth all the
way up to a thousand dollars when you
sign up for public all you got to use
all you got to do is use the good gram
that's it enjoy the free stock thank you
so much appreciate it
okay until next time
welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is reed and whatever you want to
say